[Music]
this decoding sequence is interesting
for precisely one second
after which i have regretful flashbacks
to slot machines in all their victory
so the sin as always is vegas in case
you confused it with oshkosh bagash
wait maypolling barefoot on this muddy
renfair
earth do you know how disgusting the
ground becomes after being saturated by
the tears of
larpers i love how this lady is all you
guys are dressed right
as if their futuristic combat gear is
more interesting than having just
watched them walk out of the
portal some of us need this
you know needing renaissance fairs good
thing
no one is in this tent right now in the
middle of the fair
it's always nice when people in the past
make it easier for the tva and a variant
to not screw up the timeline
none of these idiots have their weapons
activated for battle i mean at the very
least the glow sticks act as a mild
light source
on the other end of the spectrum they
can save your life if you're ambushed
which
they're about to be the trap watch your
back commander c20 then immediately
moves off on her own and exposes her
back
towards the darkness like some sort of
rookie [ __ ] also you'd think this
trap wouldn't be much of a surprise
considering there have been so many
attacks on the tva agents oh and also
they'd maybe be tipped off by the dimly
lit tint with
unattended doom fire lapping around as
if summoned by satan
we wouldn't dare play the music but the
sin as always is kids
i mean bonnie tyler also i guess the
variant is mischievous just like
loki but she can also clearly use magic
and fin for herself so why turn other
people into mindless fighting drones
just cast a spell and be done with it i
guess what i'm saying is be more like
wandavision with your spellcasting
really just in general all of these mtu
shows should be more like wandavision
in all the ways noki presses the time
door button
and then the run program option on the
menu and at no point are coordinates
entered i went along with the
unexplained logic of this contraption
because i assumed that the tva had a
special way of pre-programming
destinations but how would noki know
where the time door leads
there's something like 160 letter
changes in this opening sequence and
that is 156 changes too many
are you recording or are you alive and
while we're asking the questions
is that a stuffed weasel someone gets
sprinkles on the line for confirmation
because that poor critter will be able
to spot a fellow tortured soul from a
mile away
i'm sure the drabness of the tva office
setting is purposeful but that doesn't
make it any less depressing to look at
it's like someone said what if we could
mix the abram's star trek set with a
cleveland browns uniform then someone
else suggested what about the abrams
star trek set mixed with a cleveland
browns uniform that baker mayfield threw
up all over after a hard night of
partying then the third person said then
stayed in all in tea
meeting adjourned i don't know guys i
think i'm pretty sure i've been
brainwashed to get overly excited to
watching marvel characters don a new
outfit
this is literally just loki putting on a
suit jacket while wearing a tie and
dress shirt and
i'm screaming at my screen like yeah
this is amazing
it is not though stop [ __ ] with my
gauge on what is badass marvel
but which kind of loki remains unknown
yeah the lesser kind
to be clear vanity i don't want anybody
out there to forget what you are
there's like seven people on this
mission and loki doesn't exactly blend
in how would anyone forget who he is
why don't we just travel back to before
the attack when the variant first
arrives
oh oh oh i know this one because then
nothing about this show would be
interesting to watch and the drive for
tension and mystery wouldn't be as easy
to reach
also mobius is about to give some
gobbledygook answer about nexus events
destabilizing the time flow and blah
blah blah but what it all amounts to
is it's much more convenient to come to
this point so we don't have to witness
the event again
so show comes up with some bs rules for
time travel that doesn't answer loki's
question but words like nexus and time
flow were thrown in to make it sound
smart
got it good they're gonna move on also
has the tva never even considered that a
variant or
anyone in whatever time they travel to
could snatch one of these grenades
i understand this weaponry provides a
major plot point in this episode and
probably for the series but
why wouldn't they just have a men in
black pointy clicky thing or something
less intrusive and destructive than a
bomb meanwhile this kid is walking
around with his disintegration rod all
lit up like a dumb ass
what if loki saw a snake on the ground
jumped back and was zapped into oblivion
never ever walk around with your vamoosh
stick fully erect and activated this
is in the training videos if you leave
this tent you'll end up like them
this red herring is on for some time i
approve the missions
speaking of which let's talk about the
one you just botched
did he botch it though they were sent to
assess the situation which they did
mobius figured out loki was lying and
they reset the timeline so there were no
variances
the tva agent was missing before they
got there so that's not really on him
and say he did what he was supposed to
do the variant likes to stall for time
and eventually we'll catch the other one
doing the same thing this might be a
hard sell to the boss considering that
just moments before the mission mobius
was adamant that no two
are alike so just because one loki
stalls for time doesn't mean they all do
gonna remember this fan's reaction to
every possible easter egg in this show
somehow makes its way into this episode
i don't care
what makes you tick odd coming from a
man who just left an office attempting
to explain how getting to understand
this loki would help him catch that noki
adjusting someone else's tie without
explicit consent
i don't need your sympathy characters
delay quippy reply until the elevator
door closes cliche
wants to send the next step just once
can we have an elevator door open up
directly into the middle of a
pre-existing conversation
or even more realistic to silence
happy reading wouldn't you know it the
one file on the variant that wasn't
pulled out to be reviewed is the one
file loki has access
to which leads to a break in the case my
my no one saw this coming what a
twist and i could also
set fire to the palace no just stop
don't set fire to the palace
let's pretend that this video is a new
timeline where we haven't already given
a send back for these hiddleston and
wilson performances i may not be
enjoying most of what i'm watching yet
but these two are
gold if everything and everyone around
you
is destined for imminent destruction
then nothing
that i say or do will matter unless of
course your action actually prevented
everyone from dying or allowed a few
people to escape the area before the
destruction then it would 100
matter all kinds of time branches would
happen it's not a terrible theory but
it's also not as foolproof as loki is
making it out to be
in case you confused it with pompe
pennsylvania this entire town has wiped
off the face of its planet
how is no one noticing these two men in
suits talking under this archway
come on let's take war this is not
walking
in the early 1990s for a brief shining
moment
there was a beautiful union of form
and function which we call the jet ski
kawasaki started making the jet ski as
early as 1972 and continued to make the
stand-up version
that iso mobius is going on about until
2011. it was quite a bit more than a
brief moment in time
three magic lizards time keepers how do
these three look like
lizards who created you loki this
conversation about the similarities in
all religious and creational beliefs
goes on for
all the some time solving the mystery of
where the variant is relies on the
discovery of a pack of chewing gum
sure you can argue all you want about
the variant planting it to attract the
tva but what if mobius hadn't discovered
the chewing gum the only reason he even
questioned it was because the inside of
the kid's mouth was blue what if he
never saw the kid or the kid never even
smiled
also the detectives deduce where to go
in the timelines based on when this gum
was in production
they literally go to a store because the
store sells it
but how would they know that any of the
other apocalyptic events
did not have this gum what if it was in
someone's pocket and noki stole it
have candy on asgard yeah grapes nuts
i wonder you're so bitter grape nut
shaming this deployment squad did all of
this investigating of what they were
getting themselves into but didn't
consider that cameras might pick them up
when they walked into the store
if anyone's anyone you're me and she is
a she who they think is a he that can be
he's or she's by just
touching a knee just take it easy every
one of us can look at this man's
expression and know that he is thinking
you'd better come take a look at this
and even though it's not spoken we're
still
sinning enchantment is a clever trick is
that what you're calling brightly lit
product placement enchantment damn
marketing verbiage is getting real fancy
back in my day we just called it
manipulation
what did you give them the time keepers
where they are how does hunter see 20
even know where the timekeepers are
mobius a top agent hasn't even met the
timekeepers i get the tva as arrogant
but
that still doesn't explain why they
would let lower level agents have info
they might be tortured into giving away
if one of these missions goes awry
i just want to point out that in 2050
stores are still selling wired earbuds
i miss randy what a lot of american idol
fans said when they tuned into
season 13 somehow makes its way into
this episode why is loki going all
fisticuffs with this guy
he's got magic use magic
[Music]
okay sure this looks cool but why would
noki go through all the trouble of
wiring the devices across a massive
store when collecting them in one place
behind a locked door would do the exact
same thing
it's not like she has a ton of time on
her hands shh if you listen closely you
can hear the sounds of all the marvel
nerds clicking pause on their remotes
and scrambling to research each of these
locations
we honor all of you with this sin nice
look at how long these portals stay open
for everyone to run through
i just know the show will be consistent
with how long they stay open and never
close at the least opportune time
just to get this straight noki wired a
ton of devices to bomb the sacred
timeline
installed red lighting across the store
and to be sure the lights didn't flicker
she hooked it up to a power source so
they all visually punch the point that
whatever is happening is
real bad yeah it's too bad mobius
doesn't have an arm soldier with him
that could use a weapon on loki before
he crosses through the door
wait whatever the [ __ ] this
organizational system is
this this this
oh sure hear me complain about too many
letter ships earlier and then
add some more to it 188
shifting letters
call it dad let me finish you guys want
corn dogs
that's a temporal anomaly corn dogs
didn't come into existence till the
first half of the 20th century
we have a saying in asgard
only nixon could go to china okay look
you don't trust me you can trust one
thing
i want to kill everyone satan is good
satan is our pal my name is maximus
desmus meridius
commander of the armies of the north
general of the felix legions
loyal servant to the true emperor marcus
aurelius
you remind me of them
pull the lever
[Music]
you